I saw you guys downstairs when I first
came in but you forgot your ID yeah yeah
yeah I left it in my backpack so but
wait they ordered us with the security
so we're good
what do you do if you lose your ID you
have to fly um I guess you don't fly
there's no there's a way for them to get
you to do it like really yeah I think
they can do something but you have to go
to like a test I figured 12 ok verify
like you have a picture of my passport
on my phone so well maybe that might
help but I'm sure they you probably like
answer a whole bunch of questions that
they creepily know about you XFX Proctor
forgot his ID flying once but then he
also had weed on him so he ended up
getting arrested that was that move yeah
yeah just just a a bad combination of so
yeah no do you want did you were you
tempted to take out your Twitter or your
your passport photo well I left I left
my phone in the car too so you don't
have anything on me
why did you not sleep are you typically
forgetful or did you just well I'm just
like I don't know in New York City I'm
just I've been out of the big city for
so long that like I don't especially to
like being so deep into training camp I
like don't keep my phone on me I don't
keep like anything on me because like I
know I just feel like a lot lighter and
stuff without those things so you are
you a compulsive texture if you have it
I'm Ben I don't know it's just someone
there's just so much negativity that's
involved with the phone and just so much
like draining energy like even even like
positive things and you're just so into
it like you lose your focus on the
president and what you're doing at the
moment do you find that that the phone
drains your we're energy yeah it does
but probably not for the same reasons if
it becomes a very unhealthy thing Jimmy
hex a lot but it's not like the type of
text that you would be able to share it
a dinner table
yeah for sure I mean if I yeah probably
some if I'm like if I just drink some
tea or coffee or something I'll just
start texting a lot too but good
caffeine you mean yeah yeah for sure
but um no I just will be watching videos
and stuff so I need something all you
get caught up in a phone watching the
video [ __ ] with your training or no I
think so yeah yeah because you always
going to be in the present moment like
if you're if you're somewhere else you
know you're not in your train and you're
not
focus on just controlling your breathing
controlling your emotions and things
like that so is it annoying for you to
have to do interviews and stuff on fight
week um it can be you know but I don't
think it should be if something's like
messing with you if you allow something
to rattle you or shake you then uh then
you're not you know strong at your core
I got you and you're fighting Michelle
Waterson this Saturday eight o'clock on
Fox UFC Fight Night where is this Kansas
City okay so you leaving today yes
okay um do you get frozen yogurt because
then like we were just talking about Jim
gets frozen yogurt because he's
obviously in very good shape uh I don't
I don't think I think I've had frozen
yogurt like once before but it's
definitely not my thing it's not on your
eyes I like you this pose in yoga
basically calling me an AG homosexual
because if my male friends and I went
out to a delightful walk and had some
frozen yogurt
I enjoy oh yeah no she's not make you
very for yes I'm in Princeton you're for
a few days yeah that's exactly right
that was not a very positive statement
oh you are you and your your older
gentleman friend get some Froyo so we
called it justice is jelly because I
evil so I just started getting into this
is what I say evil or I don't yeah what
is that it's just like a such a surprise
morning fat no I hope it's just like a
smoothie or whatever but um it's acai
berry it's like it comes from Brazil or
something like that as all those
resilience are really into it it's a
superfood I heard that's what her but is
it healthier was it like one of those
myths like everybody says like avocados
amazing for you now here it has led MIT
like anything no every time I try to
know about that it's like getting paint
chips say what's that they said it was I
think everything nowadays is a little
bit contaminated it's hard to really
know what you're eating nowadays unless
you grow it yourself
well this up they found in a Walmart
salad they just found a bat
oh yes dead bat in one of those bags are
lettuce value what you're about subway
bread I guess apparently they found out
that like they there's like pieces of
yoga mat like in the bread really yeah
yeah yeah I didn't hear that
those two that's so so crazy that's why
more appetizer than the bread one with
yeah so how do you figure out what to
eat because I was thinking about that
like I anytime I even consider eating
healthy somebody there's a new
documentary about how that foods not
healthy and that's what's not healthy in
that like I don't I just yeah
ignore it all it just only eat processed
foods well that's why I just started
growing my own food I just planted a
whole bunch of strawberry plants this
past week and I grow like all my herbs
inside and I'm just like I finally got
my house so I'm finally starting to get
settled down and like starting to do
these things but eventually yeah I want
to be totally self-sufficient and I want
to be going to the grocery store it's a
lot of times with crap like it's just
hard to get around where do you live
Westminster Colorado oh okay yeah yeah
why middle of the country we raise there
you just like be there um no I in
Milwaukee Wisconsin and I always I all
my life I knew the city that's all I
knew and but I always longed for being
out in nature and things like that ever
since I was a little girl and when they
asked me what I wanted to be when I grew
up in in kindergarten I'd always say I
wanted to be a farmer and you know I one
thing led to another like it just kind
of happened so happened that a I moved
out to Minnesota for training I left
Milwaukee and then we met and mmm
Minnesota wasn't too bad I mean the
weather's obviously crap but uh I really
enjoyed training there under Greg Nelson
um he's like an amazing like he's an
excellent encyclopedia of like MMA but
we Pat my fiance found a striking coach
that he really clicked well with and so
we decided to move out to Colorado to go
train with them and I really fell in
love with the place ever since you know
they're just the outdoorsy culture and
the people are really nice and the Pat
you're talking about Pat Barry is a
heavyweight and you guys have been
dating for quite a while you're engaged
now is it difficult being around the
person all that I was always amazed with
couples who are involved is it hard
constantly I think it there's definitely
challenges you know just being a
relationship it's very there's lots of
emotions obviously but then on top of
that the coach and and student like in
fighter relationship is one also - like
- there's two different challenges
that come with those things so we
combine the coach and the student and
then the relationship with each other so
it's like it's really hard to keep it
separate but I think we won't make it
work way better than most people could I
wouldn't recommend it for everybody but
somehow we I mean we definitely we
definitely have some bumps and bruises
though along the way that we we face but
he is a way of communicating things not
just to me but just like in general like
he is really I don't know just the way
he explains things he speaks a certain
language that I can understand so if you
guys are fighting if you're in an
argument and all of a sudden going to
train you get I can't what I'm arguing
somebody I don't want to be around them
at all I need time to cool off right I'm
just being like I can't be around the
person okay let's put this aside now and
do this other task yeah how you do it I
don't know I think we just learned how
to I don't know we're very like-minded
so we don't we don't come across well I
shouldn't say that we do disagree a lot
but we don't get emotions involved some
for some reason there's times where you
know he's a lot of times he's just
trying to convince me of certain things
that like just to be you know confident
in myself you know it's it's it's not so
much of like disagreements on you know
core values you know like art what we
what's important to us we mostly grew up
agree upon but in terms of like training
and stuff like that that's where I have
to like kind of sit back and like kind
of trust him you know and know that he
knows what he's talking about but there
are times where he also respects my
opinion too and he listens to me and so
we kind of just meet somewhere in the
middle and it's definitely not a it's
not an easy process but you know
sometimes like I'm the type of person
that if if we're having an argument it
gets too escalated like if we start
yelling and stuff like that then I have
to just totally drop it like we have to
just come back to this later but you
just kind of have to be able to keep it
at a talking level you can't let it
escalate you know a friend of ours bill
talked about not name-calling in
arguments and I realize how unhealthy
that was like everything as you've ever
been and all we do is call each other
names
News do not do that yes I didn't know
how [ __ ] up I was until he said it I'm
like he's a psychopath and he's like I
doubt it's toxic oh my god
yeah yeah I mean if you're joking you
know but I got an argument
I'm not even yeah I know you're serious
I heard yeah yeah yeah yeah calling each
other impotence you know it's really
okay buddy that that was you get hit
with a lot no no I'm just saying what
what are the names are you getting hit
with just I'm too generous I'm too
giving Oh totally totally what are you
not confident in you said you'd slice
about you about confidence what do not
confident um you know sometimes I just
always feel like I got to do more you
know and I think that's just a natural
thing that all fighters have you know
like I just had to do that's not enough
you know like I already done knocked out
this perch my god dude I gotta get
something else I got to do you know
you're just always looking at the next
accomplishment you know and you're I
never stop you know and so he's really
kind of just helped me balance my
go-getter attitude my can't stop won't
stop kind of attitude I gotta bring it
back sometimes I gotta take a take a sit
down and just like relax when did you
get involved with fighting we get into
it I'm assuming as a kid yeah I I mean
my older brother always and I would
fight all the time or just like my
friends in the neighborhood we always
just fight for fun or like to defend
ourselves so that was just kind of one
aspect that I got involved but I also
was put into martial arts as a really
young girl into Taekwondo and then I got
my black bow and then I decided to move
over to karate and then from the karate
school is where I learned about
jujitsu stick fighting and some
kickboxing as well and then and then I
found Duke Rufus in Milwaukee and they
had everything there so that was just
kind of where I started my whole
mentality of just like trying everything
and I I kind of get bored of with things
pretty quickly you know so MMA is really
good for me because and I clicked well
with it in the beginning because I
always not have something to focus on
something once I'm bored with this one
thing I could focus on something else
and then like at what point what did
people think at first when they knew
this is what you're going to do with
your life because it wasn't up until a
couple years ago that
women's MMA was a kind of a thing that
was sort of I mean it was around but it
wasn't what yeah that you know I mean
right it wasn't super lucrative right
exactly
um yeah I I think um I don't think my
mom ever really knew what I was going to
do and I was going to grow up I think
she I was just always like she knew I
was going to be busy whether that be you
know music or sports or anything like
that or just something with school but
uh I don't know I I think once I made
the move to Minneapolis Minnesota that's
when it kind of was apparent that like
okay she's going for it you know like
this is no joke and then also I think
when I met Pat initially because he was
in the UFC at the time and he made it a
living even though it wasn't for women
at the time there was definitely a
opportunity like his I mean even MMA
itself was in the beginning stages and
it was still just beginning so there was
no it's not like just because the
opportunity wasn't right there in front
of me doesn't mean that it couldn't be
created and I believed in it and not
only that but I just really enjoyed it
as well you play music yeah I played the
piano I played jazz and classical very
good I think so I mean it's it I
wouldn't say like right now I'm a little
rusty but uh I could really play like a
little Justin or something but classical
is what I started in you know I have
really good classical bass but reading
music I started there you can actually
read yeah yeah mm-hmm that's what I
started in and then when I I went to
high school to arts in Milwaukee and we
did like two hours of music every day or
just whatever your art major is if you
were you know art or dance or whatever
but I chose music and then I don't know
once I once once it became like a thing
for me like two hours a day like this
serious thing then I didn't want to do
it like it was just too much it wasn't
fun yeah and I just enjoyed a punchy
people more yeah that's probably more
satisfying than tinkling on the Ivies
all it is crazy
the last time I talked to you it was uh
you discussed possibly moving and
building houses or something you you
guys are talking yeah yeah not moving
but I
Genisys I've been following this group
called airship bio texture for a long
time and what they do is they use like
recyclable materials like tires and
aluminum cans and just things that we
consider to be garbage and they use it
to build a house with in third-world
countries and stuff like that they try
to do it here but it's just they have a
community in Taos in Mexico but they
took so many years to get past all the
all the like building codes and things
like that and they have like lawsuits
and stuff so they just go to third world
countries where people need it people
are people are suing them for what is
why for building houses are for the
homeless yeah that will to try and live
that way like here because you know just
building codes are meant to keep us safe
and things like that so they don't know
these experimentation houses like if
they could be safer not but now it's
proven that I mean it's experimentation
also you kind of have to be ok with yeah
it's not going to we have to try and
build these houses first before we know
like how to make it safe so what's like
medicine when you're in a testing group
you kind of sign off to the fact that
might be a problem right right so now
they they were able to to do this and
they fought against it for a long time
but they they made a community but now
it just makes more sense to go to places
where they need it more urgently you
know and so in Indonesia it's one of the
most you know polluted countries on the
world in the world and they decided to
they're trying to make these eco regions
where they have tourism but it's in a
more sustainable way so it's not just
killing all the coral reef and
everything like that and it's such a
beautiful place I mean it's and it's
kind of sad when you just walk down the
street and there's just like a river of
just plastic and people burning plastic
just a you know just try and get rid of
it somehow so you know I went there I
got an opportunity finally at a time to
like dedicate a whole month to going
there and learning how to build them and
yeah it was a really good already yeah
you're not going to do keep telling us
you're leaving fighting and you're going
to do this no no that was back in
November and I got back in December
place went for a month okay yeah yeah
and we built an entire house and we know
it was definitely a
is a lot of adventure and I don't know
it's worried for my life a little bit I
was going to ask you if you scared that
Indonesia seems like a very scan be a
pretty radical place yeah everybody's
like super nice there but uh yeah Pat
cut his finger like the first like as
soon as we got to the island so just the
whole like the whole travel there is
just insane I mean there was like four
flights one of them was like 15 hours
and like a car ride then a boat a ferry
ride which I turns out that ferry rides
a lot of times tip over like I didn't
even realize that till coming back and
then and then another boat ride from the
ferry rides to the little island and so
like you're away from just any medical
assistance you know other than just like
a random two EMT on the island that was
staying with us but a pat cut a singer
like the first few hours have got
getting on the island and then the next
week he cut his other finger and needed
stitches and then the following week I
know and then it just like gave me a
whole nightmare like Jesus yeah new
dissection that focus on and then the
third week he fell off of a scooter so
then the fourth week we just like like
head to toe and sit down don't move and
you really got to want to build garbage
houses to do this I know my session
that's the last winter when I cut my
finger is an Indonesian island where
there's no penitent yeah so grim yeah
look at lose your finger well it
definitely takes the type of unique type
of person to want to get into a
fistfight to so it's just I'm not sure I
would probably never do that either
early if I was going somewhere to get
punched in the face I try find a way to
divert right there some like I said I
get bored with things so I need to know
it's like the I have the adventure edge
all the time so when you was there any
thought when you were there you're like
why am I here like was there any moment
we like I just sucks the beds that was a
nice tape is not comfortable my worst
and on and shitty
yeah a lot um that is made of shoeboxes
I mean my first think I was I was having
a good slow Pat was having a lot of
trouble with all the heat and stuff you
like I think he lost like 20 pounds for
the first week is he's a big guy yeah
you was definitely having trouble he was
kept cutting his fingers I don't sleep
great love stupid like what yeah
well yeah and Sam said stupid I didn't
know no I may bring Gilad tonight with
the gym and called okay Toby listen says
he doesn't know but um yeah there is
definitely a lot of times where I was
just like what am I doing here this is
so dumb
but once we find it like once I finally
saw the finished product I was really
just satisfied with what we were doing
and I feel like there was so much
adjustment needing to be made just like
having like in order to get water we had
to walk one side to the island to the
other to get water from like though a
little you know pump thing or whatever
and or you could just buy a bottle of
water so like to me it just made more
sense to buy a bottle of water excels
lazy but then all of a sudden it's like
I'm just producing all this plastic and
I'm like doing it's just kind of like my
life no the living room with it yeah I
know but I kind of like to face the
purpose over here doing you know just
like little things like that it made me
conscious of like saying like just just
learning how to survive let alone
building a house at the same time this
is a really tough challenge just to like
live in a tent for a whole month and
then we enter like you're in yeah we're
living I'm in and out that day with like
no you know we're going to spend three
weeks under no circumstance oh but
here's the thing with their use with the
water ball and you are right about the
plastic but if you think of it this way
like if you're drinking plastic it's
bottled so you're not going to get need
of the local water which could be a
stomach issue that's true and then yeah
I can do about the stomach issue I was
definitely like just the food the food
was terrible - would you eat well by the
end of the trip I was just eating a lot
of ramen noodle packets just because
like it was just so bad they would bring
food from the from like the mainland to
the island and it's like a 30 minute
boat ride to get to the island so like
there's like little shops and so for you
could get snacks and sometimes they'd
have like cooked fresh food like one of
the cooks was really nice and he cooked
really good food but other than that
like the food that they brought every
day was pretty bad they didn't feel he
was going to make you sick or put on the
toilet or they give you guys bathroom
difficult yeah I had a lot of
oh no back to balance I here's a lot of
rice and like chicken and stuff like
that but sometimes they was wasted so
sometimes it wouldn't be super fresh and
you'd have like flies and stuff or one
time the chicken came back it was like
maggots on it but oh yeah didn't eat it
no no heck no that's right from off
Jonathan my manager he's gone to like
Africa in like a lot of a lot of
countries where they sell meat outdoors
and and I've seen before his plates and
something and it just flies yeah they're
landing on the food and people hey with
this I'm like Iraq coming back yeah we
just talked to a WWE guy the Big Show
who said he had bathroom difficulties
during a match one time that's right
have you ever [ __ ] yourself in an
octagon never he's actually made yes
that happens sometimes it was famous
foods unfortunate really awkward I don't
know who it's worse for the person
happens to wear the person they're
fighting yeah yeah I know right
there's so girls I will say the one time
I when I was running track and
cross-country back in high school one
time I was running a race and I couldn't
use the air I couldn't hold my bathroom
I pee but I was just like and then I had
to go and I had another race like later
in that day so I had my mom take me home
and then come back you're messed up yeah
yeah before they did a little bit of it
so like oh this is too good
yeah you a mistake they are telling us
you have you really only had you for a
few minutes it's rose Nami honest on
Twitter and AMA Ju na s and you're
fighting Michelle Waterson this Saturday
8 o'clock on on Fox and just a 1 I guess
more fight question as a the champion
you Annie and Jay check said that you
met her and you were really nice and
then you said you wanted to fight her
sugar I think she has a problem with her
head she's and about you so what is that
about
I don't know you know I think that it's
pretty is pretty self-explanatory like
everybody wants to fight her right she's
a champ yeah ok do you think she took it
personally that you wanted to fight her
I don't know I think she's just thinking
about the wrong things I think she's
thinking about me too much I like that
when did you when did you shave your
head by the way when did you buzz your
hair off that was before I thought page
weight and with that just because you
wanted to go in and be a warrior like
that this is just the thing you wanted
to put out or is it in the way when you
fight it definitely is in the way you
know not only like actually physically
like each round taking a break and like
you know hold on let me fix my hair
but uh also psychologically you know I
never really knew what to do with my
hair I was always like a tomboy growing
up I just like I just put it up you know
so it's like it just kind of was just
there
and yeah I just know I I don't really
see the purpose in it we have a good
shaped head to it yeah you shaved your
head it was just lumpy yeah I know I was
kind of wearing a really low flat spot
right here I have a dent in the mid we
have a similar hairdo someone called a
hair don't and is a little dent in the
middle of my side of my head so this
year we oh good give a great head nod
compliment to you a person but your head
look like it works for you symmetrical